all right ted thank you for that well
the grammys are just a few days away and
two young women are expected to take
home a lot of awards our entertainment
team and i looked into why their peers
think this might be their time to shine
olivia rodrigo and billy eilish have
been taking the music world by storm
rodrigo has seven grammy nominations and
eilish has six they are going
head-to-head for album of the year song
of the year pop solo performance and
music video rodrigo is also up for best
new artist last year eilish won four
awards including song of the year grammy
nominated 98 degrees singer jeff timmon
says he does expect them to take home
some trophies olivia rodrigo i'm sure i
have a feeling she's going to be the
flavor of this year and and rightfully
so she's she's got a lot of popular hits
rodrigo had two number one hits with
driver's license and good for you but
listen to this grammy-winning rocker
sammy hagar agrees rodrigo might take
home song of the year i guess olivia
rodrigo i've heard so much about her and
my daughters and stuff i've heard her
name has popped up in my world more than
anyone else on this list i'm sorry but
yes i got to say olivia draftkings made
some odds for the show and their
prediction rodrigo and ilish will steal
the show olivia rodrigo and billy eilish
are your two favorites yeah
very close
eight to five seven to five these two
odds
separate them from everybody else here
um
to me it's a toss-up between the two two
of them the last one one of the big ones
song of the year and
it looks like it's coming down to olivia
and billy right there yeah this is
awarded to the song writer
and not the artist itself
this girl right here has been writing
some great songs this year two number
one hits
she's a little bit bigger favorite in
over eilish in this particular
particular category i think she gets
there short odds
down here when you sent me these out all
right olivia rodrigo and billy alice
will be both performing during the
grammys as well so to get ready for this
year's show we want to invite you to
watch our special salute to music it
airs on saturday at nine o'clock right
here on channel eight
sammy hager and jeff timmons from 98
degrees will tell us who they think will
win the biggest categories plus what a
fashion what fashion trends we can all
expect at the awards